[Musique]
si l'on voit, par exemple, la fourrure d'un
paresseux un verre bouger un voir
les papillons de nuit voient différents types d'insectes
Venez, voyez, c'est un endroit où nous avons
un habitat très très large et clairement
lorsqu'il y a coexistence de plusieurs types
d'organismes, il doit y avoir des systèmes
aussi qu'ils les contrôlent qu'ils ont
d'autres êtres vivants qui sont parfaitement
micro-organismes qui se tiennent à distance en
exemples d'agents pathogènes
[Musique]
Notre hypothèse est en effet que
dans la fourrure des paresseux
Il y avait des micro-organismes capables de
produire des antibiotiques qui ont permis
réguler la présence d'agents pathogènes dans
fourrure sera notre hypothèse que
Heureusement, dans ce cas, nous pouvons
dire que nous avons réussi à le vérifier
chercher de nouvelles stratégies
combattre la résistance de
antibiotiques a été laissé entre les mains de La
Academy et c'est pourquoi des projets comme
notre peut contribuer à trouver
Pourquoi pas de nouvelles molécules qui peuvent
à moyen long terme car
utilisé dans cette bataille que nous avons
de la résistance aux antibiotiques
[Musique]